Yes, absolutely. Thank you very much Dr. Bronstein for having me here and for
allowing me to mentor your students during the spring 2017 semester.
So, I am a full time employee and
graduate student at the UT Health School of Public Health, Brownsville Regional Campus.
So Brownsville is down at the US-Mexico border.
It's the farthest tip in Texas.
I've been there for about three years
and I've been working in health informatics for about four years.
So I graduated from the UT Austin Health Informatics Program,
they have a certificate program in Austin,
before coming to this job.
And I worked with our local regional health information exchange,
the Rio Grande Valley Health Information Exchange,
to connect to clinics and hospitals in the region,
and also work on an initiative called Project Diabetes and Obesity Control
which is a project from the UT system to basically
integrate data from data sources other than electronic health records so that we
can bring care to outside the four walls of the clinic.
Absolutely.
I'm really interested in
this concept of bringing data outside of
the clinical environment to the clinical environment.
Go for it.
Earlier in the course, I introduced them to the term real world data.
Real world data.
Okay, perfect.
That's probably the new term.
Okay, great.
You might regarding this term. So let's do that.
Okay, perfect. Perfect.
Should I ask the question earlier?
Yeah.
So, can you prompt me again? Sorry.
What was the project and why is it important?
I am very interested in the concept of
real world data and bringing in real world data
into the clinical environment so that practitioners and patients,
too, can be empowered with this data to make decisions about their health.
I'm specifically interested in the nutrition domain.
The project I proposed was to create a FHIR application to visualize
results from a nutrition algorithm that takes components from purchases.
It takes the physical items that were purchased from a grocery store,
scores them from zero to 100,
and comes up with an aggregate score,
displaying that alongside of data from electronic health records for
providers and for patients.
Right. Exactly. It's an approximation of their eating habits.
There's another algorithm out there called the Healthy Eating Index and that can
be used to identify the nutrient quality of the food supply or of an individual's diet.
And it's always approximating their diet.
You never know if what they bought is what they're actually going to consume.
But you can come close to assume that if this is the food that's in their house,
that's their food supply, that's probably what they're going to be eating.
And also, it's probably closely correlated with the personal choices they make.
If they buy vegetables from the grocery store,
they're probably eating healthy outside of the grocery environment.
But if they buy just meat and sugar,
that's probably what they're eating outside the grocery store as well.
But there's some studies.
I think, there was a study in 2012 that sampled,
I think it was a smaller area.
They identified, 60-80 percent of
people's food consumption comes from the grocery store and convenience stores.
We can make a pretty sure assumption
that the food that people are buying are what they're eating.
Absolutely.
There are a few nutrition algorithms that currently exist.
There's definitely a need for additional nutrition algorithms.
The one that I mentioned,
the Healthy Eating Index,
is actually far away from being implementable in a real world setting,
to actually use the data from purchases to approximate a healthy eating index score.
There are a few,
so Healthy Eating Index is one.
There's also a front-of-package labeling system called
Nouvelle which was developed by faculty at the Yale School of Public Health.
And they don't allow you, actually,
to aggregate the scores from the individual products that are purchased.
And then a third that we decided to use for our project is NutriSavings.
So they claim 85 percent market share in the US.
And one of their partners is Wal-Mart.
That probably accounts for most of the 85% market share.
But what NutriSavings does is they work with
employer-based insurance programs to score people's purchases,
the covered participants' purchases,
and they provide that information to the covered entity and also to the consumers.
We worked with them to get a sample data spec
and built sample data to populate our application.
The goals of the semester were to basically
create a mock application
that demonstrates the ability to combine these two data sources,
electronic health records and the purchasing data, nutrition algorithms,
in hopes that grocery stores will see this,
the potential of use of this real world data,
and would be more willing to share their data.
That's one thing that NutriSavings is kind of crippled with right now.
And I actually personally asked some retailers but they're reluctant
to share their data outside of the four walls of their facilities.
But we can look at the application now.
I think it would be good to show you the back end of our system
and how we imagine a clinic
working with a local grocery store to enable this application.
in this diagram, it's a bit complicated but I hope I can talk through it well,
we have data providers on the left.
These are electronic health records who are in
the area and these are clinics that have electronic health records.
And then, we have a grocery store partner and an imagined interchange or
some database that can take in the data
from the electronic health records and from grocery stores.
Ideally, this will be a FHIR compliant server that has
some other storage means for the grocery data or even,
I guess, the software application could query NutriSavings and get the data in real time.
We basically designed this for a local model.
We have a partner that is providing us with an interchange.
We wanted to implement this project after the spring.
This is why we have in this way.
And then we have Georgia Institute of Technology here
designing the front-end applications that we query for our compliant server.
Here, if a clinic is interested in becoming involved,
to get an absolute match to not have
to use a patient matching over them which we could absolutely use,
we would have the provider give the patient a NutriSavings,
calls it an employee ID because they usually work with employer-based insurance programs,
to track the patient.
And typically, NutriSavings works with rewards cards
to track people across grocery stores.
And the participant would take the rewards card to the grocery store and scan it at
a participating grocery store which would identify them across
the electronic health record and with
a grocery store and would allow that data to be shared with NutriSavings.
And NutriSavings currently generates
three types of data so they can provide a trip score for individual grocery trips,
items received at those trips,
and then also a monthly summary for that participant.
We thought it would be good to
allow the provider to see all these different types of granularity.
But also see a monthly score at the high level.
I'll show you the front-end application now.
The front-end application, we have Jane Smith here.
We decided to make this as simple as possible
for this could be a registered dietitian or a provider.
During our spring project,
we interviewed two register dietitians and two M.D.s for the project.
And then, we also had some consultation from a consulting firm.
And this just basically shows a tiled view of
different relevant clinical items from FHIR resources, from the EMR.
We have like a respiratory rate, hemoglobin A1C, glucose,
HDL, LDL, BMI and the actual nutrition score.
We could integrate additional metrics as needed.
But these were some that the registered dietitian thought were
important for further practice.
We have a high level of view here where
the provider can see all of these different tiles,
and if they click into one,
we're clicking into the nutrition score,
they get a graph view that shows the monthly summary for the patient over time.
And if the provider were to click into any of these month points,
they could see the trip summaries over time as well.
This was a very simple tool.
We wanted to do a minimal viable product but
some things that we think could be incorporated are like a notes function,
a goal setting function.
Unfortunately with this, we don't have a very high level of granularity.
We're only seeing the monthly score and the individual scores.
This nutrition index just shows the nutrient density of different items purchased.
Somebody, for example, somebody could
just buy apples for an entire month and their score would be 100, right?
The scale is from one to 100.
But just eating apples is not enough to fulfill all of your nutritional requirements.
I think there's a huge need to get
more granular data from grocery stores and actually like working with NutriSavings,
they weren't able to share
that granular data and they're only able to share these nutrition scores,
these aggregate nutrition scores.
I think it's absolutely necessary that we get more granular data both so that we can
develop additional algorithms that are more granular,
and so that we could actually provide clinical decision support.
I think, I love the CDS Hooks Initiative that's going on right now.
I think would be great if we could build some CDS Hooks that are relevant
to nutrition and we need access to that granular data.
I'm hoping that as we build more of these applications,
we can use this to show grocery stores that
there's utility for this data and hoping that if we build it,
they'll come and they'll give it to us.
I think that's a good overview of the software application.